todo está listo para el comienzo de una
nueva era política en alemania y una
nueva de la política también hasta
cierto punto en europa la era de olaf
scholz como el nuevo canciller de
alemania como el noveno canciller de
alemania de la posguerra los tres
partidos que formarán parte de su
coalición del gobierno los
socialdemócratas los verdes y los
liberales aprobaron de manera interna en
el acuerdo de coalición que será firmado
de manera oficial en la mañana del
martes aquí en berlín los tres partidos
también anunciaron ya quienes serán los
ministros quienes formarán parte del
nuevo gabinete alemán se destacan el
vicecanciller hugo match a bacon líder
de los verdes así como anna lenna de
abbott también con líder de lo
era mujer en liderar el ministerio de
asuntos exteriores por su parte cristian
una de los liberales asumirá el muy
importante el ministerio de finanzas
alemán se espera que olaf scholz el
próximo miércoles en la mañana tome su
juramento como nuevo canciller de
alemania con lo que también así se pone
punto final definitivo a los 16 años de
gobierno de angela merkel aquí en
alemania